KEVIN WINTER: Hi everyone.
As I was introduced, my
name is Kevin Winter.
I am a developer programs
engineer here at Google on the
developer relations team.
And I support the AdWords API.
I am going to be talking
about some updates to
reporting for v201109.
To start off with, the v13
Report Service was introduced
a while ago, also
pretty limited.
v13 Report Service
is fairly old.
It has been around
for a while now.
It was originally intended to
be sunset in August of 2011.
So starting with v201109, we're
using kind of a new
paradigm, a new way of
approaching reports.
Calls to the API
ReportDownload Service are free.
We have a number of improvements
we have been
making to v201109 to make it a
very suitable replacement for
running lots of reports and
removing some of the downsides
of v201101.
And making it a much more viable
alternative to v13
cross client reports than
v201101 ever was.
So to give you a quick example,
this is what a
v201109 Report Definition
looks like.
It's fairly straightforward.
As I mentioned before,
you have a selector.
Which in this case, only
has a list of fields.
You can add predicates to the
selector to specify, I only
want to get my active
campaigns.
Your report name is mostly for
your own use at this point.
You can still specify
the Report type.
Your Date Range type, which
will be using one of these
dynamic date ranges we
added in v201101.
Or you can use a Custom Date
Range, and specify them on the
fly for three quarters ago,
which is something the current
dynamic date ranges
don't support.
When making an AdHoc Report
Request, as mentioned, you
actually send the report
definition as the HTTP request
body when downloading
the report.
You can make an HTTP POST
Request, or you can make an
HTTP GET Request. And I'll go
to that in a few seconds.
But when you make these
requests, you need to still
specify authentication and
ClientCustomerID headers.
As I'll get into later, you're
going to only be able to use
ClientCustomerID in 201109
and forward.
The body of the requests will
need to be URL encoded.
In the previous example,
when I showed you the
ReportDefinitionXML, it was
not simply for clarity.
But when you're making this
request, you will need to URL
encode the body.
This is just in case you
have any non-URL safe
characters in this.
And when we interpret
the request, we know
exactly what you mean.
You're going to want to use a
name parameter, __rdxml, to
reference the report
definition.
So when you send your Report
Request, you can use the
content type of form URL
encoded, which is a very
common content type.
This is supported by many HTTP
libraries in many languages.
And all you need to do is just
make sure that you do URL
encode the body and use
the request parameter.
It is going to be __rdmxl.
So when you're making report
downloads, you still need to
specify some form of
authentication.
A lot of times when you're
managing a lot of reports, we
strongly recommend that you use
an MCC account to manage
these accounts.
And you use an Auth Token
requested for
that specific MCC.
So when you download your
report, the only thing that's
changing every time is the
ClientCustomerID header.
The other option you now have is
OAuth authentication, which
is new for 201109.
You can now use OAuth to access
the MCC, or even the
individual accounts, if that's
the way you'd want to do it.
And you can sign each individual
group or download
request using the OAuth access
token and still specify the
ClientCustomerID to identify
which account the
report will be for.
So here's an example of how a
Report Request will look.
You have your URL, which as you
may note, is now version.
You now have adwords.google.c
om/api/adwords/reportdownload
which was your normal URL.
And it's now /v201109.
This is also new for 201109.
The key benefit of this is
that now we can start
versioning report downloads.
So instead of having us make a
change that changes the way
the reports return, we can now
make them in a version change
without having you worried
about your code instantly
breaking because we have to fix
a bug or make some change
that, when your code is relying
on a slightly older
version of the API.
You're still going to use your
HTTP POST Request header, such
as ClientCustomerID.
Your authorization, which will
have the Auth token specified
at the Google login.
And your content type
is form URL encoded.
And the request body would look
very similar to this,
except that, as I keep
mentioning, it does need to be
URL encoded, just to make sure
that we can correctly
interpret your request.
So now we're going to show you
in Java how you can download
that report using a very
simple library.
So we're defining a very simple
interface here, where
you are specifying the Auth
token, the CID, and the
ReportDefinitionXML, which are
the three key components.
If you're downloading for a lot
of accounts with an MCC's
Auth token, the only thing that
will be changing when you
make this request will be the
CID for each of these
subserver requests.
In our case, we're using an HTTP
URL connection, which is
built into the Java JPK.
It's also supported on App
Engine, if you ever decide to
develop for App Engine.
And what we do is we open a
connection to our Report
Service URL.
We then set DoOutput, which is
basically saying we're going
to be putting stuff in
the request body.
We set our request
properties, ie.
HTTP headers, for our
ClientCustomerID, the
authorization, and
content type.
And we set the RequestMethod
at the POST. Because we're
going to be posting the
message to them.
Then we're going to just obtain
a OutputStream Writer.
And wrap that around the
OutputStream for the HTTP URL
connection, so we can write
directly to the request body.
Next, we write our parameter,
__rdxml.
And then we URL encode our
ReportDefinitionXml.
As I said, so we can interpret
it properly.
Then we simply get the response
code, which actually
makes the request and interprets
the response, and
gets to know what
the result is.
I'll get into what these status
codes will mean for you
in a little bit.
But in our case, we're simply
checking is the response OK?
Which means that the report
download was successful.
And in this case, we're simply
creating a temporary file.
We are copying function body
omitted from the input stream
of the connection to the output
stream of the file.
And we're just closing that
and returning back in
reference to the file.
There are a lot of things
you could do right here.
You could write it into
database, do some later
processing, what have you.
But in this example, this
is all we're doing.
So when the Report Request
finishes and you get your HTTP
response code, these codes will
mean different things.
200 is OK.
It means your report downloaded
successfully.
The response body will contain
your report as requested.
400 indicates a BAD_REQUEST.
It means that there was
something wrong about the
request that you made.
Maybe you forgot to URL encode
the report definition.
Maybe you're missing a header.
Maybe you didn't specify the
content-type properly.
These will return as 400.
500 is an INTERNAL_SERVER_ERROR.
This covers any number
of things.
It could be a transient
temporary failure.
It could be some other sort
of internal problem.
But generally, this is the type
of issue that shouldn't
normally be happening.
You should be able to retry
after a short wait
just to make sure.
Another thing is, we will get
RATE_EXCEEDED_ERRORs if you
make too many report requests
too quickly from here.
So you definitely want
to double check this.
And if you get this, you want to
delay before making another
request just so that you don't
hit our servers too much and
get blocked.
The other thing to mention is
that when you do get anything
other than a 200, the response
body will contain some text
that will tell you a little
bit more about why you
received this error.
It will tell you that your
report definition was invalid.
Or it might say that just the
request itself was wrong.
But it will give you some
more information.
We also have an explicit flag
for getting Rows with Zero
Impressions.
In v201109, we will not include
Zero Impression Rows
unless you explicitly add this
header and set it to True.
So we also added a new
CRITERIA_PERFORMANCE_REPORT.
A lot of people have
asked for this.
We previously had our
KEYWORDS_PERFORMANCE_REPORT,
URL_PERFORMANCE_REPORT.
Now there's a simple
CRITERIA_PERFORMANCE_REPORT
that includes all of
these types of
criteria in a single report.
So you can get consistent
statistics across all of your
criteria in a single report,
instead of requiring several
reports or relying on special
behavior and the
KEYWORD_PERFORMANCE_REPORT.